when did Indy ever go to Tangier who
does Jurgen Valor remind us of and what
happened to Indy's son mutt there are
plenty of small details to unpack in the
dial of Destiny and we're here to break
them down spoilers ahead while Raiders
of the Lost Ark in the Last Crusade were
World War II adjacent with Indy
traveling across the world to stop Nazis
from obtaining ancient Supernatural
artifacts Indiana Jones has never been
shown fighting in the actual War itself
even the last film in the original
trilogy Crusade was set in 1938 a year
before Hitler invaded Poland dial of
Destiny changes that with an eye-popping
15-minute action scene starring a young
Indie as he infiltrates and escapes a
Nazi Fortress later saving his friend on
a Nazi train this is also where he
steals back half of the antakithra from
a younger version of Jurgen baller the
fact that Indian listed and fought
covertly in World War II shouldn't
surprise anyone despite his
well-documented hatred of the enemy in
the previous films Indy's military
service isn't directly referenced until
Crystal Skull in that film after the
area 51 and nuking the fridge sequences
India is interrogated by stuffy G-Man
Stooges they mention Indy's exemplary
military service before admonishing him
with the suspicion he could be a spy we
did 20 30 missions together in Europe
and the Pacific don't wave your War
record in our face Colonel Jones we all
served in dial of Destiny after the
exciting World War II prologue the film
cuts to a much older Indiana Jones now
70 nearly a decade younger than the
actor playing him living in a small
messy apartment Indy is now much older
and crankier and viewers are introduced
to him getting annoyed by Young
neighbors partying there are of course
mementos and references to his past
Adventure strewn throughout his
apartment one that stands out is a
painting of the magical leap of faith
Bridge as seen in the climax of Last
Crusade in that film Indy has to cross
the bridge relying on his biblical
knowledge to get to the other side it
was the last test Indy had to overcome
to get to the coveted Holy Grail before
the Nazi villains it makes sense that
Indy would keep this particular Memento
as this happened during an adventure
with his father played in that film by
Sean Connery the test was also a
monument mental accomplishment for Indy
as he succeeded in that task due to his
wits and historical Knowledge from the
lion's head
improve his worth of course it's also
just a fun Easter egg for a production
designer to sneak in there for the fans
dial of Destiny is set in 1969 and part
of its backstory involves the Apollo 11
moon landing it stated that the main
villain of the film Jurgen voller who
goes by the much less conspicuous name
Dr Schmidt is a former Nazi scientist
scooped up by the United States
government at the end of World War II to
help build rockets for NASA that idea
wasn't pulled out of thin air it's based
on a real US government program called
Operation Paperclip essentially during
World War II German scientists developed
V2 Rockets some of the most advanced at
the time afterwards once the Nazis
surrendered their Tech scientists and
research were all up for grabs paperclip
served as a scientific Advantage for the
U.S helping significantly with getting a
jump on the Space Race over 1600
scientists as well as engineers and
technicians came over from former Nazi
Germany as Nazi scientists were given
Sanctuary by the United States
government one of the most prominent was
Werner Von Braun who worked on the
Apollo 8 mission and helped develop the
Saturn V rocket that landed American
astronauts on the moon it was eventually
discovered that Von Braun had worked as
a rocket scientist for Nazi Germany
during World War II thereby aiding the
fascist regime in developing the V2
rocket while he had denied direct
culpability to Nazi cruelty documents
were later discovered that showed
evidence to the contrary according to
Empire Mass Mickelson's villainous
Jurgen voller is based on von Braun
memories a little fussy
fuzzy are you still a Nazi telling
details in the film include feigned
ignorance of Nazi war crimes carried out
in Hitler's name as well as pretending
to be apolitical and geopolitical
Affairs which turned out to be false for
both Von Braun and the fictional Valor
celebrity impersonators have long been a
staple of Comedy the potential audience
for impersonators seems to be larger
than ever in the age of the internet and
social media and Harrison Ford has
become an oft caricatured celebrity due
to his unique Cadence and universally
recognized charmingly curmudgeonly
demeanor this includes Mark Hamill who
acted alongside Ford in the Star Wars
films and has been known to do a great
impression of his co-star on talk shows
Hey kid
it ain't that kind of movie one of the
better Ford impersonators however is
actor YouTuber Anthony ingruber who even
played a younger Ford in 2015's the age
of Adeline you're welcome in fact he was
so good many people wanted him in the
role of Han Solo for 2018 solo which
ultimately went to Alden ehrenreich
according to solo co-writer Jonathan
kazden whose father Lawrence Kasdan
co-wrote Raiders of the Lost Ark and
Gruber did indeed audition for the film
in dial of Destiny and Gruber is playing
double for young Indiana Jones in the
1944 flashback at the beginning of the
film he can also be seen briefly in a
blink and you'll miss it Cameo as one of
the Shady gangsters in Tangier who
surrounds Indie and Helena Shaw during
her illegal auction in dial of Destiny
after Helena and her kids sidekick Teddy
complain about an older Indie driving
during a car chase in Tangier he replies
currently I know Tangier between the
release of the original Indiana Jones
Trilogy and the long-belated Crystal
Skull there was a TV show adaptation
entitled The Young Indiana Jones
Chronicles I'm going to be an
archaeologist tonight the series ran for
two seasons from 1992 to 1993 on AVC
spanning multiple decades in its story
lines Chronicles had Corey carrier
playing Indie as a young boy and Sean
Patrick Flannery playing the adventurer
as a young man with a framing device
that cast actor George Hall in the role
of an older Indie in the present day
re-edited Chronicles episodes and some
newly shot footage resulted in my first
Adventure which tells the story of a
young Indiana Jones finding himself
adventuring in the Moroccan city of
Tangier although Temple of Doom is the
second film it's a prequel to Raiders of
the Lost Ark it follows Dr Jones as he
searches for a sacred stone and in the
process finds himself saving kids who
were stolen from a poor Village and
turned into Slaves by an evil ancient
cult the film's Gory violence had a hand
in creating the PG-13 rating some have
also criticized it for harmful
stereotypes and misleading
representations about the practice of
Hinduism despite that the film is also
remembered for some amazing action set
pieces its epic and grandiose production
design and introducing the world to
kihui Kwan who would go on to win an
Oscar for everything everywhere all in
once Short Round step on it
in dial of Destiny Indy mentions such
Adventures to Helena while climbing a
cliff wall toward Archimedes tomb she
asks Cindy why he stops climbing at one
point and he explains it's because of
all of his various injuries including
what happened to him dealing with
Supernatural Voodoo in India that has
led to his body having some significant
mileage on it one of the biggest
contributions that the Miss begotten
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull film
brought to the broader Indiana Jones
lore was the introduction of Indy's
long-lost son Mutt Williams played by
Shia LaBeouf you're not my dad okay you
bet I am in fact the ending of that film
greatly implies that mutt will take over
as lead of the franchise going forward
the last scene even has mutt picking up
Indy's iconic Brown Fedora ready to put
it on before Indy takes it back at the
last minute Le buff ended up leaving the
franchise which created a much-sized
hole in the plot of any sequel however
director James Mangold decided to give
mutt a surprisingly emotional narrative
send-off in dial of Destiny at one point
Helena asks what Indy would change if he
could go back in time and he says he'd
stop his son mutt from enlisting and
getting killed while it's never stated
explicitly that mutt died serving in the
Vietnam War it's obviously what India is
referring to and it gives audiences some
closure on mutt's fate the Nazis are
once again the villains for Indiana
Jones and dial of Destiny this time
around valer's plan is to kill Hitler
and take over leadership duties using
his knowledge of the future and his
supposedly carrier intellect to win
World War II however the way time travel
works in the film involves the
antichythera simply using calculations
to find fissures in time to travel
through this means the calculations were
made thousands of years ago and valer
didn't account for the Earth's
continental drift so instead of going to
World War II they find themselves in the
siege of Syracuse where baller and his
men's plane are shot and blown up by the
Greek and Roman army this is similar to
the spirits from the ark melting the
Nazi villains faces and Raiders or them
drinking from the wrong Cup in Last
Crusade even without indie's help Nazi
hubris always seems to do the men
there's really only one thing you can
say about each one of these Nazi bad
guys he chose
boiling Indiana Jones by being a
character living in the past who has
Adventures throughout the world has
sometimes crossed paths with famous or
inFAMOUS historical figures this
includes meeting Hitler during his rise
to power in the Last Crusade losing his
virginity to matahari in an episode of
the young Indiana Jones Chronicles and
meeting Teddy Roosevelt Pancho Villa and
Lawrence of Arabia in that same show he
even meets Han Solo at one point in a
comic book well he meets Han Solo's
skeleton but close enough in dial of
Destiny Indy once again meets a great
historical figure in this case any
travels to ancient Greece during the
siege of Syracuse eventually Indy meets
the great mathematician and inventor
Archimedes they exchange some words as
the battle between the Greeks and Romans
rages in the background and Indie even
thinks about staying to witness history
unfold before Helena knocks him sense
into him at the end of Crystal Skull
Indiana Jones and Mary and Ravenwood
tied the knot however at the beginning
of dial of Destiny it's made clear by a
separation notice that he and Marion are
in the process of a divorce whatever
spark had been reignited in the last
film it is once again dissipated is
explained in the film this is because
after the death of Mutt Williams in
Vietnam their marriage began to dissolve
as Marion succumbed to grief Indy
himself admits to Helena at one point
that he wasn't equipped to console a
spouse at the end of the film Indian
Helena find themselves stranded in
ancient Greece after the Nazis defeat
themselves and he decides he wants to
Live and Die in the past witnessing
ancient history first hand since he
feels like he has nothing to live for in
the present anymore Marion however is
convinced to come back presumably by
Helena and reconciles with Indy in 1969
giving him a reason to want to live
again their final lines are reminiscent
of a scene from Raiders of the Lost Ark
As She searches for a place to kiss him
that doesn't hurt it's a small nod that
makes for a fun cute Coda for the
storied Indie franchise
thank you